next to ride the wheel is Cody Ryan
Kyle the blood feels to be rushing quite
quite well it looks like a tomato so
vibrant Amanda and Michael no help me
don't let me foul Lord Jesus
[Laughter]
here we go
oh Jesus Mercy who
would you most trust with your life
Amanda she's an ER nurse she's an ER
nurse guys would have to be the yard
nurse I mean that's what she does she
says loves
Amanda fascinating wheel Riders
Kyle I'm sorry Amanda but a little Ryan
Ryan Cody
you're up to nine thousand five hundred
dollars
[Music]
I might have to start looking at Cody
and Ryan it's the good old boys club
right I don't want Cody getting too
close to the faithfuls
that could plowed his judgment and I
don't want that
who is most likely to Google themselves
who is most likely to Google themselves
oh man I don't know
Kyle
oh boy wheel Rider
Kyle is the popular choice to Michael
show us your answer
sorry guys I thought Ryan
10 400 so far let's hurry up because
Kyle's got to get up and Google himself
again so
I mean I'm having a blast this is a
really fun mission but it became way
more personal who
is the most two-faced
on this wheel
that's brutal right to be two-faced you
gotta tell some lies so oh
we're wasting time we're wasting time I
need an answer
Michael very interesting Michael what
would you say I think they're going to
say me
we'll take it yes yeah
queer Riders reveal
it's 11 900 in the Park yeah buddy I
know where they stand on me and I'm
already Shady business anyway so I went
along with the group and said me but
yeah no it's not me whose Behavior has
changed the most since arriving yeah
questions were perfect everyone is so
sure and Michael's a traitor
Mike are you having a bit of a tough
time on the wheel today absolute tough
time brother I got a wedgie about the
vomit
who is the least likely to win a Nobel
Peace Prize I mean definitely stirs
apocalo I'll take it I'll take it part
of this is trying to reach consensus and
anticipate who's gonna vote what and
part of this was Michael being pretty
good natured like hey guys let's win
this money but I still think he's a
traitor Kyle is it going to be a full
house
it's all good money in the pot baby in
the pot time is up stop the wheel
good job
Michael Michael Michael
Trader Trader Trader